and now represent the best achievement
in special visual effects Karen black
who were so lovely and five Easy Pieces
and whom we will soon be seeing in the
film version of port noise complaint
Richard Chamberlain whose performance of
Shakespeare is one of the few by an
American actor to have been acclaimed
all over the world
when angela lansbury sails through the
air and dinosaurs walked the earth there
helped more than a little by the
magicians who create special effects you
see Karen don't tell me I believe
everything I see in the movies and I
don't want to know how they do it for
best achievement and special visual
effect the nominees are Alan Mae Lee
used to slice set and Danny Lee for Walt
Disney's Bedknobs and Broomsticks
Jim Danforth and Roger Dickon for Warner
Brothers when dinosaurs ruled the earth
the winners are Allen Mamie and used to
slice set and Danny leave for Bedknobs
and Broomsticks
a number of people have said that this
is rather difficult to explain but in
the technical Awards there's not much
it's citement I can assure you when
you're up here that Simon is ecstatic
ladies and gentlemen of the Academy
thank you very much